where does the campaign 1966 batman
movie fit in among the grim and gritty
dark knight films of the 21st century
keep watching because the answer awaits
you could make a case that 2005's batman
begins is a more practical starting
point for a neophyte than 1989 smash hit
batman by director tim burton there's a
solid basis for that argument and it has
to do with character motivation in
1989's batman eventual joker jack napier
murders young bruce wayne's parents in
front of him traditional versions of
batman's origin depict nervous
incompetent anonymous mugger joe chill
gunning down poor thomas and martha
wayne that might sound like a trivial
change but it actually makes a
significant difference by removing the
randomness and mundanity from batman's
foundational violence and attributing it
to a major super villain burton makes
batman's vendetta about a specific evil
dude rather than the abstract concept of
crime
so why is 1989's batman the place to
start
it's simple this version set the
standard for the plethora of superhero
blockbusters to follow between its
record-breaking box office returns and
the corresponding merchandising bonanza
that followed batman was everywhere
during the final year of the 80s we are
still feeling the ripples it's enormous
splash left in the cinematic marketplace
thus it makes sense to watch this batman
before batman begins because without the
former the latter would have never been
made
if you start with 1989's batman then
your best bet for sustained continuity
is the path laid out by the 90s batman
movie timeline that makes her second
stop tim burton's follow-up 1992's
batman returns this sequel marks michael
keaton's second outing as the caped
crusader and also boasts michelle
pfeiffer and danny devito delivering
quintessential performances as catwoman
and the penguin respectively with its
dark fairy tale aesthetic and emphasis
on damaged outcasts batman returns
probably has more in common with other
tim burton projects like 1990s edward
scissorhands than most other superhero
movies it's certainly too macabre for
small children which is why there was
such a huge backlash after warner
brothers deployed misleadingly
kid-friendly marketing including
mcdonald's happy meal toys
but as long as you keep the kitties away
from this flick you'll have a great time
you will however notice a major
departure and tone once you move on
burton and keaton both left the caped
crusader behind following batman returns
and the decision makers at warner
brothers rattled by the backlash decided
gotham city needed to get a lot less
gothic
a more accurate title for 1995's batman
forever might be the bright knight
returns fans have been describing joel
schumacher's pair of batman movies as
torturous viewing experiences for years
they're certainly a lot more colorful
and less serious than either burton
movie and as a certain cultural critic
once asked why so serious
1995's batman forever was a commercially
successful film though reviews were
mediocre at best it is also utterly
consumed by the all-encompassing black
hole of kinetic absurdity that is
mid-90s jim carrey fresh off megastar
turns in 1994's ace ventura pet
detective and the mask carries
relentless rubber-faced riddler devours
this movie much to the chagrin of
co-star tommy lee jones carrie told noor
macdonald that jones was very upfront
about his disdain for him and he went
like to hug me and said i
hate you
and jones wasn't the only cast member
having a rough time effectively
immobilized by his heavy bat suit vel
kilmer left the batman franchise after
batman forever in order to work on
movies where he got to act instead of
just fill a rubber costume still batman
forever is entertaining and an important
step in the dark knight cinematic
evolution notably it marks the first
time bruce wayne's introduction to dick
grayson is captured on the silver screen
while the movies are more expensive and
in theory designed for a broader
audience the most influential version of
batman from the 90s is undoubtedly
batman the animated series this 1992
cartoon takes its tonal cue from the
burton films while presenting a
thoughtful emotionally mature
kid-friendly iteration of gotham city so
why did warner brothers think they had
to make batman a grinning goofball to
appeal to children when their own tv
show based on the same intellectual
property made a strong case to the
contrary who knows
but we live with the result 1997's
batman and robin batman and robin
combines the intellectual development of
mighty morphin power rangers with the
camp of the 1960s batman tv show but not
as good as either basically the plot
entails george clooney's batman almost
breaking up with robin because dick
grayson is visibly pushing 30 and makes
no sense as a boy wonder meanwhile
arnold schwarzenegger occupying the
villain spot as mr freeze alongside uma
thurman's poison ivy deploys a deadly
array of absolutely terrible ice puns
it's groanworthy it's tiresome but if
you get some friends together who are
down to laugh at a low point in batman's
history it can be pretty fun to hate
watch
after batman forever and batman and
robin have conditioned you into
processing a campy caped crusader you
should be more receptive to the
wholesome hijanks of adam west and burt
ward in 1966's batman the movie
essentially a feature-length episode of
the 1960s television series this flick
is defined by a massive villain team up
the joker the penguin catwoman and the
riddler are all present batman the movie
also includes shark repellent bat spray
a dehydration device that reduces its
victims to powder and a sequence in
which our hero declares
some days you just can't get rid of a
bomb
while there are certain rules batman
always has to follow to remain a
coherent character adhering to grim
humorlessness and brutality are not
necessarily among them if the joel
schumacher films are bad it's because
they rely too heavily on
commercialization not because they let
batman smile every once in a while the
mid-60s live-action batman endures as a
positive example of a family-friendly
bright night
galvanized by a need to course correct
for the empty-headed neon flamboyance of
batman and robin warner brothers tapped
christopher nolan then known for
directing psychological thrillers like
2000's momento and 2002's insomnia with
nolan at the helm they would pull batman
back to his gritty street level roots
2005's batman begins marks the start of
a new timeline events that unfold in the
burton and schumacher movies never
occurred in this iteration of gotham
city christian bale's bruce wayne
transforms from self-destructive rich
kid to ninja trainee to terrifying urban
protector with nary a bad credit card in
sight the performatively immortal razal
ghoul doles out his master plan more
like a megalomaniacal bond villain than
any literal or figurative clown the
closest thing to camp comes in the form
of scarecrow a living haunted house prop
with a vicious streak scarecrow steals
his share of scenes in batman begins he
could have been the breakout gotham
villain of his generation had it not
been for the arrival of an even more
deranged update of a batman enemy in the
follow-up film
if you're going to watch just one batman
film it should be 2008 the dark knight
not only is this thematically rich
sequel to batman begins widely
considered the greatest batman movie but
many believe it's the best superhero
movie of all time christopher nolan
along with brother jonathan nolan and
prolific screenwriter david s goyer
delivers a psychological action thriller
for the ages heath ledger set the
precedent by which live-action super
villains continue to be judged christian
bale maggie gyllenhaal aaron eckert and
gary oldman crank out stellar
performances as well though they're all
instantly overshadowed ledger's joker is
simply too spectacular to be ignored you
want to know how i got these scars
tragically and famously ledger passed
away at the age of 28 before the dark
knight was released he went on to win
the academy award for best actor in a
supporting role for his work as the
joker in order to examine 2012's the
dark knight rises for what it truly is
we have to push a mountain of critical
discourse aside every possible opinion
about the dark knight rises has been
debated at length is it the best batman
movie ever is it the worst batman movie
ever is it in between the fact is
anything following the dark knight was
always going to feel like a tiny bit of
a letdown if you accept that however
you'll realize this film has a lot to
offer bale is as strong a batman as ever
going out on a definite high note as for
the villains and hathaway adds a world
weary sense of snark to catwoman's
classic moral ambiguity that works like
gangbusters and then there's bane tom
hardy's genuine presence as the masked
baddie is irresistible even if you can't
always understand what he's saying
generally speaking most people agree
that joel schumacher's version of batman
wasn't very good most people also agree
that christopher nolan's version of
batman was very good but there's no
consensus on the most polarizing batman
of all as tons of fans both love and
hate zack snyder's take on the dark
knight whatever your personal take on
batfleck happens to be it's safe to say
that 2016's batman vs superman dawn of
justice is where the caped crusader gets
real
weird after observing that superman can
level an entire major city whenever he
feels like it batman devises a plan to
put the man of steel in the ground or
maybe lex luthor manipulates batman into
going after superman we're still not
entirely clear on the plot of batman vs
superman which received infamously
terrible reviews what is clear is that
ben affleck is doing his best to play a
batman who has lived long enough to
become the villain
if your purpose in this endeavor is to
watch every batman movie then the 2017
edit of justice league overseen by
director joss whedon and 2021's zack
snyder's justice league the re-edit
released on hbo max both do the trick
these two films tell essentially the
same story and are equally relevant to
batman's overall place in the pop
cultural universe but if time isn't a
factor since the snyder cut is literally
twice as long as whedon's two hour
justice league we think even the most
adamant snyder critics would probably
admit his take is better whedon's film
has its moments but it ultimately
amounts to a bland exercise in pushing a
handful of intellectual properties
through the market demanded motions
meanwhile the snyder cut is a maximalist
cataclysm of r-rated action fantasy
lunacy 2017's justice league is a
corporate product it is not art the
snyder cut is also a corporate product
but maybe it is art either way one thing
is absolutely certain there's definitely
more batman stuff in the snyder cut just
as there is more of literally everything
else
the batman open to generally positive
feedback and appears as though it will
more than likely produce a sequel or two
however for right this second it's a
provisionally standalone film whose
identity within batman's film ubra has
yet to fully take shape but even though
it's the most recent movie and thus
logically the last one you should watch
there are actually a few different
options for placement of the batman in
your movie marathon from the standpoint
of its central character's evolution the
batman could fit before the burton
schumacher series though it's not an
origin story in the traditional sense
robert pattinson's depiction of bruce
wayne is a hero who's a little
underbaked he only starts growing into a
hyper-competent crime smasher resembling
the guy from 1989's batman at the
movie's conclusion then again since
culture and world events of the 2000s
heavily inform nolan's trilogy maybe it
makes more sense to watch the movies in
their real world release order as the
batman director matt reeves infuses
sentiments of the 2010s and early 2020s
into his gotham city saga we do not
recommend watching the batman
immediately before or after the 1966
batman because the tonal clash between
paul dano and frank gorshin's
interpretations of the riddler may cause
the viewer some internal whiplash or
psychic damage gorsuchian's riddler
never successfully kills anybody while
danos riddler kills a whole score of
folks in nasty ways
no word though on how tommy lee jones
feels about either of their performances
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
batman are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]